JOHN ROBERTS LIVE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THANKS.
TRACE.
>> Trace: THE NEW YORK BAR
CO-OWNER IS NOW FACING CHARGES
FOR ALLEGING RAMMING HIS CAR
INTO SHERIFFS DEPUTIES.
THEY RELEASED THIS VIDEO OF THE
INCIDENT.
PRESTI SAID THE OFFICERS DIDN’T
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES.
LAURA INGLE IS LIVE IN STATEN
ISLAND, NEW YORK.
WHAT ELSE IS PRESTI SAYING IN
MISS DEFENSE?
>> HE IS SAYING, TRACE, THAT HE
DIDN’T DO ANYTHING WRONG WHEN
IT COMES TO THAT INCIDENT WITH
THE SHERIFFS DEPUTIES BECAUSE
HE TRULY THOUGHT THAT HE WAS IN
FEAR FOR HIS LIFE.
WE’RE STANDING OUTSIDE OF THE
PUB NOW.
MAC’S PUBLIC HOUSE.
THE NEW YORK CITY SHERIFF’S
DEPUTIES SAY THEY WERE
OBSERVING PRESTI AND HIS CREW
WATCHING THROUGH A SIDE
ENTRANCE BUT THEN AFTER
MIDNIGHT THEY SAY THE PRIEST
TEE CAME OUT THE FRONT DOOR AND
WALKED DOWN THIS BLOCK.
A HALF BLOCK AWAY AND RIGHT
WHEN HE TURNED THE CORNER THAT
IS WHEN THE INCIDENT WENT DOWN
WITH THE SHERIFF’S DEPUTIES.
PRESTI’S ATTORNEY PROVIDING
THIS VIDEO OF THE INCIDENT.
THE NEW YORK CITY SHERIFF SAYS
THE TWO OFFICERS IDENTIFIED
THEMSELVES BEFORE PRESTI RAN
INSIDE HIS JEEP HITTING AND
CARRYING THE DEPUTY ON THE HOOD
OF THE CAR 100 YARDS.
PRESTI CLAIMS THE TWO PEOPLE
DRESSED IN DARK CLOTHING NEVER
IDENTIFIED THEMSELVES.
HIS ATTORNEY SAYS THAT PRESTI
FEARED FOR HIS LIFE AND THOUGHT
HE WAS ABOUT TO BE ROBBED OR
JUMPED.
>> HE DOESN’T SLAM INTO WHOEVER
IS ON THE HOOD OF THE CAR.
HE SLOWLY STARTS TO DRIVE AWAY
WITH THE HOPES THAT THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ATTACKING HIM ARE
GOING TO GET OUT OF THE WAY.
>> THE NEW YORK CITY SHERIFF
HAD A DIFFERENT TAKE SAYING TWO
UNFORMED DEPUTIES IDENTIFIED
THEMSELVES AND APPROACHED MR.
PRESTI AND TRIED TO TAKE HIM
INTO CUSTODY FOR CRIMINAL
THINGS OBSERVED.
THE PURSUING DEPUTIES ORDERED
HIM TO STOP BUT HE FAILED TO
COMPLY AND ENTERED HIS VEHICLE.
THE BAR HAS BEEN THE SITE OF
PROTESTS AFTER OWNERS DECLARED
IT AN AUTONOMOUS ZONE REFUSING
TO CLOSE EVEN AFTER THEIR
LIQUOR LISTENS WAS SUSPENDED
FOR IGNORING COVID RESTRICTIONS
AND PRESTI’S ATTORNEY TOLD ME
EARLIER THIS MORNING THEY PLAN
ON HAVING A CHAT LATER TODAY ON
THE PHONE AND THEN THEY’LL GET
THEIR DUCKS IN ORDER AS THEY
PROCEED TO FIGHT THESE CHARGES
AND TRY TO GET THIS BAR
REOPENED.